[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من الرياض
والتي نقدم من خلالها ابرز اخبار وملفات
السعوديه والخليج نبدا بالعناوين
بعد تطويقها بشكل شبهي كامل فاجنر
الروسيات تعلن السيطره على بلده جديده في
المنطقه الصناعيه في بخموت
تفويج اكثر من مليونين معتمر منذ بدء
الموسم العام الجاري الى الخارج وتسيير 59
الف حافله بين مكه وجده
ولتطوير اساليب البناء الحديث في السعوديه
صندوق الاستثمارات يبرم اتفاقيه للاستعانه
بالتقنيات في قطاع الاسكان
في الرابعه ايضا
العربيه في احد اكبر المصانع السعوديه
لانتاج الدواء في القصيم والذي يصدر
الادويه الى 34 دوله
هيئه الغذاء والدواء ترفض دخول اكثر من
خمسه الاف صندوق من الكماء بسبب التعفن
والفطريات
مساء الخير ونبدا من التطورات المتسارعه
في شرق اوكرانيا وتحديدا بخ موت التي
اوشكت على السقوط في يد الروس فقد اعلنت
مجموعه فاجنر الروسيه تحقيق قواتها تقدما
جديدا في المنطقه الصناعيه في بخموت وسط
معارك عنيفه مع تحسن القوات الاوكرانيه
داخلها وذكرت فاقدر في بيان قواتها تمكنت
من السيطره على بلده
قوي رغم نقصي امدادات الذخيره والسلاح
واشارت الى اقتراب تطويق مدينه باخموت
بالكامل حيث نشرت صوره تشير الى سيطرتها
على 5 مدن محيطه بالمدينه
ومع التقدم الروسي في الشرق الاوكراني
اعلن الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ان
روسيا تعمل بنشاط على زياده قدرتها
الانتاجيه للاسلحه الجديده واكد بوتين ان
زياده انتاج السلاح مهم لروسيا في الوقت
الحالي ومستقبلا واكد خلال كلمه ضروره
اشراف المدعين العام على تحديث مؤسسات
الصناعه الدفاعيه بما في ذلك زياده
القدرات لانتاج اسلحه اضافيه
اتهم مجلس الامن الاوكراني روسيا بالسعي
الى توسيع النزاع ليشمل اطرافا اخرى بعد
حادثه سقوط مسيره امريكيه فوق البحر
الاسود وقال الرئيس المجلس اوليكسي ان
الهجوم الروسي على المسيره الامريكيه يشكل
اشاره من بوتين على استعداده لتوسيع رقعه
النزاع واقحام اطراف اخرى فيه
من جانبها اكدت الرئاسه الروسيه الكرملين
عدم وجود اتصالات روسيه امريكيه رفيعه
المستوى بعد حادثه المسيره فوق البحر
الاسود واشهر المتحدث باسم الرئاسه
الروسيه
انا روسيا مستعده للانخراط في اي حوار
بناء ومن جهه اخرى قال بسكوب ان الرئيس
بوتين سيبحث مع نظيره السوري بشار الاسد
حزمه من القضايا بينها العلاقات السوريه
التركيه
من احدث المسيرات الامريكيه تمتلك مواصفات
تكنولوجيه عاليه
يعتمد عليها الجيش الامريكي في العمليات
العسكريه سرعتها تصل الى 300 كيلو مترا في
الساعه
قادره على التحليق لمده تصل الى اكثر من
30 ساعه تصنف بالطائره متعدده المهام
القدره على الرصد والمراقبه ومهاجمه اهداف
على الارض يمكن تسليحها بصواريخ هيل فاير
وكذلك بقنابل موجهه بالليزر نفذت ام كيو 9
مهمه في العراق وافغانستان وسوريا ودول
اخرى وفق تقارير استخدمت في اغتيال قاسم
سليماني وفي اغتيال زعيم تنظيم القاعده
ايمن الظواهري صحيفه واشنطن بوست تشغيل
الدرون ام كيو 9 يتم عن بعد بواسطه فريقين
في نح و 20 قاعده منتشره في 17 ولايه
امريكيه
اصدر قاضي في محكمه لاهورا العليا قرارا
يامر فيه قوات الامن بتعليق اجراءاتها
لاعتقال رئيس الوزراء الباكستاني السابق
عمران خان حتى صباح غد الخميس وطلبت
المحكمه انتظار ما ستعلنه محكمه اسلام
اباد العليا بشان التماس او التماس الذي
قدمه الفريق القانوني لعمران خان لالغاء
مذكره الاعتقال ضده فيما يعرف بقضيه
الهدايا وكانت الشرطه اعلنت في وقت سابق
لانسحاب من محيط منزل عمران خان بعد
اشتباكات عنيفه مع انصاره
من جانبه قال رئيس الوزراء الباكستاني
السابق عمران خان ان الحكومه تريده وراء
القضبان لمنعه من المشاركه في الانتخابات
وقال خان لوكاله الانباء الفرنسيه ان
مذكره الاعتقال الصادره ضده ليست بسبب
خرقه لاي قانون لكن الحكومه تريد حبسه حتى
يتم منعه من دخول الانتخابات المقرره في
وقت لاحق هذا العام
اعلنت منظمته طب الطوارئ الايرانيه عن
مقتل ملا يقل عن 19 شخصا واصابه 2500
اخرين في حوادث متصله باحتفالات ما يعرف
بالاربعاء الاحمر في عموم ايران وتوعدت
الشرطه الايرانيه في بيان لها باعتقال
المخالفين ومن اعتبارتهم مخاطرين بامن
المجتمع
في لبنان اجلت الدائره القضائيه جلسه
التحقيق مع حاكم مصرف لبنان رياض سلامه
الى غدا الخميس بسبب تغيبه عن الحضور هذا
وطالبه وزاره العدل اللبنانيه باعتقال
حاكم مصرف لبنان وشقيقه ومساعدته وحجز
املاكهم بعد توجيه اتهامات لهم بالاختلاس
والثراء غير المشروع وغسل الاموال من جهه
اخرى وصف فريق الدفاع عن حاكم مصرف لبنان
استدعائه للمحاكمه امام قضاء اوروبيين
بانها انتهاك للسياده
اكدت الصين انها لا تسعى الى تحقيق مصالح
بشكل اناني او تكوين تكتلات حصريه في
الشرق الاوسط وقال المتحدث باسم الخارجي
الصينيه وانجوينج ان الصين اقترحت مبادرات
لحل المساله السوريه وحل الدولتين
يشهد الشرق الاوسط اكثر القضايا سخونه في
العالم وكصديقه جيده لدول الشرق الاوسط
ليس للصين مصالح انانيه ولا تسعى الى
اقامه تكتلات حصريه في المنطقه ودائما ما
تكون وسيطا يعتد به ويتمتع بحسن النيه
اقترحت الصين مبادره من خمس نقاط في الشرق
الاوسط واقتراحا من اربع نقاط للمساله
السوريه ورؤيه من ثلاث نقاط لحل الدولتين
فيما يتعلق بالقضيه الفلسطينيه ومؤخرا
سعادت الصين السعوديه وايران على اجراء
محادثات في بكين اسفرت عن نتائج عظيمه
رابع مستمره وفيها
اليه تبريد الطرق تخفض درجه حراره الاحياء
السكنيه فهل يشعر المواطنون بالفرق
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله من جديد كشفت وزاره الحج
والعمره عن تفوج ما يزيد عن مليونير الى
خارج السعوديه وذلك منذ بدء موسم العمره
للعام الجاري وبحسب احصائيه حصلت عليها
العربيه فان عمليات التفويج لقوافل
المعتمرين من خارج المملكه جرت وفق اليه
معينه بتنسيق مع الجهات ذات العلاقه ومن
خلال تسيير 59 الف حافله في عمليه التفويج
عبر مركز طريق مكه المكرمه جده السريع الى
مطار الملك عبد العزيز الدولي
من مركز تفويج المعتمرين في طريق مكه جده
سريعه ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه سلطان
السلمي اهلا بك معنا سلطان لا نشره
الرابعه انقل لنا الصوره لديك
اهلا بك فاطمه اهلا بكافه مشاهدي قناه
العربيه نتواجد حاليا داخل مركز تفويج
الحجاج والمعتمرين هنا في طريق مكه جده
هذا المركز الذي يعمل على تنظيم عمليات
خروج المعتمرين المتوجهين الى المنفذ
الجوي ونذكر بذلك مطار الملك عبد العزيز
الدولي بثلاث بصلاته الثلاثه مجمع صلاه
الحجاج والصاله الشماليه والصلاه الجنوبيه
يعمل هذا المركز على التاكد من عدم خروج
الحافلات الممتلئه بالمعتمرين الا قبل
موعد رحلتهم بسته ساعات لايصال الجنوبيه
وثمانيه ساعات لاصاله الشماليه وصاله
الحجاج لحتى لا يكون هنالك عمليات تكدس
وازدحامات داخل صالات مطار الملك عبد
العزيز كما حدث في وقت سابق لذلك هذا
المركز يعمل على تنظيم العمليات لخروج
المعتمرين من مكه وكذلك هنالك مركز اخر
مثل هذا المركز في المدينه المنوره للتاكد
ايضا من عدم الخروج الا في وقبل مواعيد
الرحلات بوقت محدد يتم وضعه من قبل وزاره
الحجر السعوديه وكذلك شركات العمره اريد
ان اخذكم في نموذج عملي يتم ادخال هذه
الباصات في خمسه مسارات محدده هنا على
طريق جده مكه يتم التاكد من اعداد
المعتمرين داخل هذه الباصات من خلال وجود
مراقبين داخل هذه الباصات معهم بعض
الكشوفات التي بها اعداد المعتمرين وكذلك
تصاريح مكتب او شركه العمره ومن ثم يتم
الدخول اليها وبعد ذلك يتم اعطائهم كشف او
نموذج يتم تسليمه
للسائق او مكتب العمره لتسليمها في المنفذ
الجوي اذ هنالك ايضا نقطه مركزيه ونقطه
تفويج كذلك في مطار الملك عبد العزيز
بصلاته الثلاثه الشماليه والجنوبيه وايضا
مجمع صلاه الحجه كذلك يتم توزيع بعض
الوجبات وكذلك المياه على المعتمرين في
حال
وجود الباص داخل او الحافله داخل هذه
المركز قبل موعد اقلاع الطائرات الخاصه
بهم بثمانيه ساعات يتم ايقافها والانتظار
حتى يتم الموعد الخاص او خروجها من مكه
المكرمه في موعدها الخاص مزيد من التفاصيل
ينضم الى الاستاذ حسين العدني وهو مشرف
مركز التفويج هنا في
مركز تفويج الحج حجج المعتمرين هنا في مكه
المكرمه وتجددا خط جده مكه السريع بدات
على شاشه العربيه كيف يتم التعامل مع
الباصات التي تخرج من مكه قبل موعد
الانطلاق او موعد اقلاع الطائرات الخاصه
بها اهلا وسهلا بقناه العربيه واهلا فيك
استاذ سلطان
فيما يتعلق بالحافلات اللي تجي في وقت
مبكر يتم التعامل معاها
بالتعاون مع شركات العمره
والزامهم بعدم المغادره الا في الوقت
المحدد لهم كذلك تثبيت مخالفات على
الشركات
[موسيقى]
التفويج لاحظت ان هناك مكاتب طيران وخطوط
وكذلك اعاده طبيه في حال انه عدم مرور
بهذه النقطه كيف يتم التعامل قد تخرج الخط
السريع مباشره عدم المرور بكم
في فرق للنقابه العامه للسيارات وكذلك
بالتعاون مع
قياده قوات امن الطرق بيتابعوا موضوع دخول
الحافلات لمركز التفويج على مدار 24 ساعه
شكرا لك يعني كما رايتم هنالك مشرفين
ومراقبين من وزاره الحجر السعوديه للتاكد
من عمليات التفويج وخروج المعتمرين قبل
موعد رحلتهم بثمانيه ساعات او حتى 6 ساعات
كذلك هنالك خيار اخر قد يرغب بعض
المؤتمرين بالتنزه داخل مدينه جده هنالك
نموذج يتم تعبئته من قبل شركه العمره
وكذلك وزاره الحج ليسمح لهم بالوصول الى
مدينه جده والاستمتاع بالساعات قبل موعد
رحلتهم الى في مطار الملكه الدولي كذلك
يعمل بهذه الانظمه في مركز تفويج المدينه
هناك في المدينه المنوره لتنظيم عمليات
خروج المعتمرين بشكل سلس وبشكل نظام نعم
شكرا لك من مركز تفويج المعتمرين في طريق
مكه جده السريع مراسل العربيه سلطان
السلمي
بوتيره متسارعه يشهد قطاع البناء في
السعوديه تطورا من حيث اساليب البناء
الحديث ومجال التشييد وفي ظل هذا التسارع
شهد منتدى صندوق الاستثمارات والقطاع
الخاص المنعقد في الرياض توقيع مذكره
تفاهم مع مبادره البناء الحديث في وزاره
الشؤون البلديه والاسكان المذكرات تهدف
الى استكشاف فرص تطوير اساليب البناء
الحديث والتقنيات ذات الصله لخدمه التوجه
المستقبلي لقطاع الاسكان وقطاع الانشاءات
في السعوديه وسعيا الى تنميه المحتوى
المحلي في مجال التشييد والبناء
من جانبه ذكر المشرف العام على مبادره
البناء الحديث في وزاره الاسكان السعوديه
ان مذكره التفاهم مع صندوق الاستثمارات
السعوديه تكمن في معرفه الفرص المورده في
القطاع العقاري والتركيب البناء وتطوير
الكوادر البشريه في السوق
وفخورين جدا بعلاقتنا المستمره مع صندوق
الاستثمارات العامه وبتوقع الاتفاقيه
اليوم العلاقه كانت سابقه ومستمره وتوقيع
الاتفاقيه اليوم هو خطوه اساسيه ومحوريه
في علاقتنا المستمره بمشيئه الله الفكره
طال عمرك هو استمرار العلاقه مع صندوق
العامه بمعرفه الفرص الموجوده في القطاع
على مستوى سلسله القيمه بشكل كامل على
مستوى التصنيع على مستوى اللوجستي على
مستوى تركيب واستخدام البناء الحديث في
زياره التبني في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وعلى مستوى ايضا تطوير الكوادر البشريه في
جميع سلسله القيمه هذه حنا نشوف اليوم ان
في فرص عظيمه جدا على جميع مستويات سلسله
القيمه هذه سواء من ناحيه التصنيع من
ناحيه النقل من ناحيه التركيب من ناحيه
الديزاين من ناحيه الاموره في التقنيات
المس انده ومن ناحيه تبني اعاده تقنيات
سواء بجانب
التطوير العقاري او الجانب الصناعي
في ظل الاقتصاد المتنامي وانتشار المشاريع
السكنيه الضخمه في البلاد يواجه السوق
العقاري في السعوديه تحديات اعده منها
التنافسيه بين القطاع العام والخاص في ظل
التنافس في القطاع العقاريه التجاري فضلا
عن تحد اخر يكمن في فرض الرسوم الحكوميه
والضرائب وتاثيرها على المشاريع والصفقات
العقاريه كما يرى رواد الاعمال في المجال
العقاري وفي ظل التحديات ايضا يرى خبراء
في المجال لان احتكار المطورين العقاريين
اضافه الى نقص خبرات بعضهم اسهم في اتساع
الفجوه بين العرض والطلب في السوق مطالبين
في الوقت ذاته بضروره السماح بدخول
المستثمر الاجنبي للسوق المحليه الامر
الذي سينتج عنه على اثره فتح باب
التنافسيه وكسر الاحتكار الحليب هذا
بالاضافه الى تحديات تتعلق باساليب البناء
وتطويرها من حيث السرعه الشكل ومواد
البناء
ينضم الينا في الاستوديو المهندس المعماري
تركي الحصيني اهلا بك معنا معماري يعني
تحديات كبيره ذكرناها قبل قليل في خبرنا
تواجه او يواجهه سوق العقاري في السعوديه
من وجهه نظرك انت ما اكبر او ابرز هذه
التحديات حياك الله مرحبا وشكرا للاستضافه
هو السوق عندنا بالسعوديه مفتوح بشكل كبير
والسوق يعني مهما دخل فيه مطورين ما راح
يلبي الحاجات شفنا تجربه وزاره الاسكان
الاخيره في في طرح عده اساليب للبناء سرعت
من طرح وحدات كثيره في للسوق للمحتاجين
والمنتفعين منها كان لنا تجربه جدا جميله
في وزاره الاسكان قدمنا تصميم وايضا وزاره
الاسكان اتفقت مع عده مكاتب سعوديه يعني
فيها معماريه سعوديين وهذا اللي خلى تجربه
تنجح بشكل كبير ويكون الاقبال على مشاريع
الاسكان يعني هي طرحت
مسابقه او طرحت استقطاب المهندسين وقعت
عقود مع عشر مكاتب من ضمن مكتبنا انه
قدموا تصميم مميز معماري قليل التكلفه
ويخدم العائله ممكن يتوسع مستقبل
فعده مكاتب قدمت ويعني تخيل ان هذا
التصميم للفله ممكن يمشي على بريكاس يمشي
على البنات التقليدي على الحديد البارد
على الالمنيوم يعني فيلا تخيلي مثلا 375
متر تكلف في وقتها قبل يعني كورونا اعتقد
كانت 400 الف وهذا سعر جدا جميل هذا قبل
ارتفاع بشكل بسيط وحتى المده كانت بسيطه
يعني يمكن يخلص الهيكل الانشائي بخلال
اعتقد شهرين او اقل هل هذه معماري من
البيوت التي تجي جاهزه وتتركب في في شيء
جاهز اللي هو البريكاس وفي حاجه تنبنى
بالموقع حتى نظام لبشر اللي هو بدون قواعد
وحفر كذا فتجربه وزاره الاسكان مع المكاتب
المعماريه السعوديه جدا ناجحه سرعت في طرح
الوحدات السك واستقطاب المستفيدين من
الوحدات للي طلع التصاميم جدا مميزه اشكال
مرتبه ممكن الفله تكبر مستقبلا مع العائله
يعني احنا طرحنا نموذجين واحد بثلاث غرف
نوم بحركه بسيطه ممكن يطلع عندك غرفه
اضافيه اللي هي صاله بالدور الارضي
وغرفتين نوم فوق وجلسه بالسطح يعني
هي اضافه بسيطه بس فتجربه وزاره الاسكان
بعد هذه التجربه مع العشره المكاتب تخيلي
دخل برضو 15 مكتب في التصميم الداخلي
والمعماريه
في ربما الاسعار العقاريه لنراها
وزاره الاسكان الاخير اللي هو ضاحيه
الفرسان طرحوا شقق ب 350 الف تقريبا
والسوق الان شقه نفس هذه اعتقد بحول 900
الف فهذا يخلي التنافس يعني حتى مع اللي
ينافسون وزاره الاسكان
يخفضون الاسعار او يطرحون منتجات ممتازه
باقل تكاليف والطرق البناء الجديده هذه
معماري هل تواكب متطلبات سوقنا هل تواكب
احتياجات الاجواء عندنا اكيد هو مع ارتفاع
الاسعار العالميه في مواد البناء وغيرها
احنا لازم نطلع عن نمط البناء التقليدي مع
انه هو يفضل يعني افضل شيء والبناء
التقليدي لكن في الحديد البارد في
البريكاس ممكن انا ابني 1000 فله بغضون
مثلا سنه اذا كنت انا عندي مثلا قوالب
الالمنيوم القالب الواحد اللي يشكل لي
الفله الهيكل الانشائي يستخدم على 800
فيلا تقريبا هو يكلف تقريبا مليون يخفض
التكاليف ويسرع موتيره العمل طبعا الوحدات
كلها راح تكون متشابهه تقريبا لكن احنا
يهمنا بالنهايه نوفر وحدات سكنيه بسعر
مناسب خاصه انه الاراضي في الرياض عاليه
جدا يعني المتر كان تقريبا الف ريال اليوم
6,000 فلازم انا احط معادله اللي هي تخفيض
تكلفه البناء وايضا بما يساهم يعني مواكبه
الجو الحار الشديد لدينا في الصيف مثلا
يعني نحن نتحدث لاحقا عن طرق جديده مبتكره
في محاوله تخفيض درجات الحراره لدينا فاء
المواد المستخدمه في البناء اليوم هل
تحافظ على ذلك يعني انا رايت في معرض
البناء الاخير معماري ان فيه مواد ربما من
الفلين المقوى او الى ذلك اللي حنا نسميه
يسمونه هو الكوت او تلبيس المبنى بالتغليف
لكن بعد
1/7 اللي هو القرارات الجديده نظام الكود
السعودي الجديد راح ينتهي البناء التقليدي
واللي يعني خلينا نقول دخلوا على مهنه
البناء والعماره
بشكل عفوي راح تنتهي بعد التنظيمات
الجديده ويكون المكتب هو المسؤول عن
المبنى والمقاول وتقديم الضمان
وتقديم كل يعني ما يضمن ان المبنى يكون
سليم انشائيا ومعماريا ويكون
مكيف بشكل جميل ويناسب الاجواء بالرياضه
يعني هذه اخبار جدا مفرحه ويعني تجلب
الامل بالذات الان في هذه الفتره اللي في
اقبال كبير على البناء والترميم شكرا لك
جزيلا المعماري ترك الحصيني لوجودك معنا
في استديوهات العربيه في الرياض الله
يحييك شكرا
بالاضافه الى انها تسهم في توفير بيئه
اكثر راحه في مناطق الانتظار والمناطق
التي يتجمع فيها الناس
ينضم الينا المتخصص في هندسه النقل والطرق
الدكتور علي ميليباري بعد قليل للحديث
اكثر عن هذه الاليه الجديده في تبريد
الطرقات ولكن ننطلق الى الرياض والسفاره
الامريكيه التي اعلنت مصادقه مجلس الشيوخ
الامريكي على تعيين السفير المعين مايكل
راتني سفيرا لدى المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وقالت السفاره في حسابها على تويتر اننا
نتطلع الى الترحيب بمايكل راتني في الرياض
ووفقا لوزاره الخارجيه فان الراتني هو
عميد كليه دراسات اللغه في معهد الخدمه
الخارجيه في وزاره الخارجيه وهو موظف قديم
في السلك الدبلوماسي منذ العام 1990
الرابعه مستمره وتتابعون
داخل ادوات صحيه السعوديه تضبط اكثر من
اربعه ملايين قرص مخدر
[موسيقى]
بعد تطويقها بشكل شبه كامل فاجنر الروسيه
تعلن السيطره على بلده جديده في المنطقه
الصناعيه في بخموت
تفويج اكثر من مليونير منذ بدء الموسم
العام الجاري الى الخارج وتسيير 59 الف
حافله بين مكه وجده
لتطوير اساليب البناء الحديث في السعوديه
صندوق الاستثمارات يبرم اتفاقيه للاستعانه
بالتقنيات في قطاع الاسكان
العربيه في احد اكبر المصانع السعوديه
لانتاج الدواء في القصيم والذي يصدر
الادويه الى 40 دوله
احييكم من جديد في السعوديه تجاوز عدد
المصانع الدوائيه المسجله اربعين مصنعا
تغطي 36% من احتياج السوق السعودي من
الادويه وبحجم نمو يقدر بخمسه في المئه
سنويا بجانب حجم الصادرات التي تجاوزت
مليارا ونصف المليار ريال فيما يقدر حجم
السوق لهذه الصناعه باكثر من 34 مليارات
ريال ويصدر احد اكبر مصانع الادويه في
القصيم الى نحو 40 دوله
من احد مصانع انتاج الادويه في القصيم ما
ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه نصفيان اهلا بك
معنا هاني اذا انت في احد المصانع التي
تنتج الادويه وتصدرها الاكثر من اربع
وثلاثين دوله حدثنا اكثر عن هذا المصنع
نعم فاطمه في حقيقه الامر بعيدا عن عمليه
التصدير هذا المصنع يعتبر اكبر المصانع
الموجوده في السعوديه واحد اكبر المصانع
لانتاج وصناعه الدوام على مستوى المنطقه
اليوم نتحدث عن مصنع مساحه تتجاوز 150 الف
متر مربع اليوم ايضا الى جنب عمليه الجوده
والحفاظ على الجوده وعمليه التطوير للدواء
والانتاج والصناعه هذا المصنع يعمل
بالريبوتات وايضا يستخدم التقنيه في عمليه
التغليف وعمليه التوزيع وعمليه الفرز
عموما جميع هذه المعلومات واكثر سوف يكون
ضيفي المهندس عبد الله الرشيدي وهو مدير
عام المصانع في الدوائيه مرحبا بكم مهندس
عبد الله واليوم نتحدث عن مصنع يقوم
بعمليه تصدير ينتج ما نسبته من سوق
السعوديه سته او ثمانيه في المئه يصدر الى
اكثر من 43 تقريبا او 34 دوله في الخارج
ايضا ارقام اخرى وتقنيه متوفره في هذه
المصنع طبعا حنا الان في اكبر واول مصنع
في السعوديه
طبعا المصنع طبعا يعتبر طبعا
من اكبر مصانع في المنطقه طبعا انتاج اكثر
من 400 منتج في هذا المصنع المصنع طبعا
ينتج جميع الاصناف العلاجيه المختلفه
لدينا قدره انتاجيه في هذا المصنع مما
يقارب اثنين مليار وواحده على جيب السنه
بالنسبه طبعا المصنع هو طبعا انت جميع
الاشكال سواء كانت اشكال الاقراص
والكبسولات نظام الحقن والاشربه الجافه
والاشربه السائله
الحيويه فيها طبعا هو يعتبر احد مصانع
شركه الدوائيه السبعه احنا طبعا لدينا
سبعه مصانع في في اتبع اتابع الدوريه هو
يعتبر اكبرها
خلينا نتكلم برضو بجانب الدوان يتكلم
اليوم عن عمليه التقنيه كيف استطاعتهم
ادخال هذه التقنيه خاصه نتعامل اليوم مع
هو يستخدمه الانسان يعني صحيح طبعا المبدا
طبعا صحيح طبعا المبدا الاساسي لديه طبعا
هو رفع كفاءات الجوده والتوثيق وثيقه في
المنتج وسلاسه وسلاسه الانتاج فالاداء
طبعا في جميع المراحل الانتاجيه من عمليه
تصنيع اذا عمليه تغليف اذا طبعا عمليه
التخزين بما فيها طبعا مثل اللي هو الصرف
العميل النهائي
الاوتوماتيك ورقمي ساعود لك تخيلي فاطمه
ان هذا المصنع لا نشاهد في اي كادر بشري
يقف على هذه التقنيات نشاهد عمليه الفرز
ونشاهد عمليه التطوير ايضا لي العناصر
الطبيه والتي سوف ايضا يتحدث فيها معي
المهندس عبد الله ولكن لعل الصوره الان
نشاهد هذه احدى او احدى الروبوتات التي
تعمل كناقله لنقل الدواء هي تاتي فارغه
ومن ثم تقوم بنقل هذه الصناديق طبعا نتحدث
في المرحله الاخيره من المصنع ومن مساحه
المصنع مهندس عبد الله اليوم نتكلم عن
عمليه تطوير لعناصر الدواء يعني الامر
اليوم هل فقط انتاجكم على مجرد بنادول او
مسكن لالام الراس ام الموضوع
لامراض اخرى تقومون بانتاج اول صناعه
ادويه لامراض اخرى طبعا صحيح معلومه
هننتجه في الفيديو ليس بنادول ولكن طبعا
مركز متطور
المنتج طبعا مركز متطور وحديث تقنيه طبعا
التطوير التطوير الادويه لدينا الان
تقريبا 13 منتج تحت مسجل الان حديثا
باضافه على دينه 110 منتج تحت التطوير
شكرا لك مهندس عبد الله اذا العربيه كانت
تواكب خط الانتاج من داخل احد اكبر
العناصر او احد اكبر المصانع الموجوده في
المنطقه واكبر المصانع الموجوده في
السعوديه ولاحظنا ايضا وشاهدنا مع مشاهدي
قناه العربيه كيفيه عمليه انتاج هذا
الدواء عبر التقنيات الموجوده وكذلك
المهندس عبد الله من خلال الارقام
والتفاصيل التي تحدث فيها وعن الجوده وعن
الكفاءه وعن عمليه تطوير الدواء في
السعوديه شكرا لك من احد مصانع انتاج
الادويه في القصيم مراسل العربيه نصفيان
وشكرا لضيفك الكريم
نعود مشاهدينا الى اليه تبريد الطرق التي
تناولناها قبل قليل ومعنا من جده حول ذلك
المتخصص في هندسه النقل والطرق الدكتور
علي مليباري اهلا بك معنا دكتور علي يعني
اليه جديده
تحولون تجربتها الان سؤالي لك على ماذا
تقوم هذه الاليه تحديدا
تحياتي لك
طبعا هذا الاليه هدفها هو تخفيض درجه
الحراره على الاحياء السكنيه نعرف طبعا
يعني درجه الحراره عاده وهذا مثبت علميا
دائما في المناطق الريفيه وخارج الطاقه
العمرانيه تكون اقل من درجه الحراره في
داخل الطاقه العمراني بالتالي يعني
في الطرقع بالسعوديه ما شاء الله شبكه طرق
طويله واشعه الشمس يعني اغلب مده تكون
مسلطه بشكل قوي تكون درجه الحراره عاليه
وبالتالي تؤثر على خلينا نقول مشهد
الحراري مشهد الطقس بالنسبه والمناخ
بالنسبه لهذه الطرق وهذه الاماكن بالنسبه
للطاقه العمرانيه جاءت هذه الفكره طبعا من
قبل الهيئه العامه للطرق بالتعاون مع
وزاره الشؤون البلديه والقرويه والاسكان
من خلال المختبر المركزي التابع للهيئه
العامه للطرق بعد طبعا مسح ادبي ودراسه
تجارب ودول عده
ما يقارب سته شهور ونيف حتى تم التوصل الى
تصنيع مواد علميه
امنه طبعا بيئيه بعيده عن التلوث يستطيع
من خلال هذه الماده تستطيع ان تقلل من
امتصاص الطرق لاشعه الشمس لما تكون مسلطه
بشكل قوي على على الطرق هذه الطرق عاده
يعني تمتص 90% من اشعه الشمس
نصف درجه ام حتى الى درجه ربما
لا لا هذه الماده وجدت لان ان تقلل من
امتصاص اشعه الشمس بدل ما تكون في المئه
تكون اقل وبالتالي حيكون هناك في فرق كبير
جدا احس فيه مين
المناطق المحيط اللي في نطاق العمراني
يعني حتى درجه الحراره تكون خفيفه حتى
استهلاك الطاقه نحن نعرف البيوت اللي حول
هذه الطرق دائما يعني طبيعي بحكم الحراره
بحكم الحراره بعثه من الطريق بالذات في
الليل هي الفكره ايش الفكره عندما تمتص
هذه الطرق عاده من غير هذه الماده في
الحاله العاديه 90 في المائشات الشمس في
الليل يتم انبعاث هذه الحراره في الليل
وبالتالي تكون درجه مرتفعه على مدار اليوم
وبالتالي الاماكن الحول او الحياه السكنيه
اللي حول هذه الطرق تصدر الى تستهلك
الطاقه من خلال اجزاء التبريد والتكييف
عندما يتم تقليل هذه درجه الحراره على هذه
الطرق اذا استهلاك الطاقه واستخدام اجهزه
كيف حيكون قليل اضافه الى التلوث
البيئي وايضا يعني نتكلم على التاثير على
تغيير المناخ يعني حيكون هناك في اثار
قليله في نقطه مهمه حتى الناس اللي هم
عبور المشاه الناس اللي جالسين في
الاستراحات في الحدائق في اماكن انتظار
على الطرق ايضا سيحسوا بنوع من عدم
الحراره بالطريقه التقليديه السابقه حيكون
هناك في نوع من الحراره المعتدله المعقوله
ونتكلم الان بالذات احنا قادمين على فصل
قاعدين على
الارض
طبعا الحين تطبيقها يتم طبعا كاي تجربه
علميه يعني دراستها يتم تطبيقها بشكل
ممنهج بشكل نموذج على منطقه معينه وهذا ما
تم الان حييته من قبل الهيئه العامه للطرق
بالتعامل القرويه في احد الاحياء السكنيه
لاداه الطاقه العمرانيه
سيتم تم تجربته هذه الماده والى نتائج
يعني جدا تبحث على على التفاؤل نتائج جدا
جيده طبعا تتم التقييم منها هناك عده
معايير ابرزها مدى رضا السكان على هذه
التقنيه من خلال استبانه ستكون هناك مطلع
بعد ذلك عندما يتم التاكد بالنجاح هذه
التجربه اي تجربه علميه سيتم تعميم على
جميع شوارع المملكه التي تدرسها طبعا
بالشكل عامل الطرق بالتعامل البلديه
والقلويه والاسكان واضح شكرا لك من جده
المتخصص في هندسه النقل والطرق دكتور علي
ملباري
اعلنت مديريه مكافحه المخدرات في السعوديه
عن احباط محاوله تهريب نحو 4 ملايين الف
قرص من ماده الام فيتامين المخدر في جده
مديريه مكافحه المخدرات اوضحت ايضا ان
شحنات المخدرات كانت مخباه في شحنتي ادوات
صحيه عبر ميناء جده الاسلامي كما جرى
ايقاف المتهم باستقبال شحنه المخدرات
واحالته الى النيابه العامه
في السعوديه نبقى حيث رفضت هيئه الغذاء
والدواء ادخال اكثر من 5000 صندوق من الكم
بوزن يتجاوز 12 الف كيلوغرام
وردت عبر منفذ الحذيفه او الحديثه خلال
شهر واوضحت الغذاء والدواء ان كميات
الكماء المرفوضه تبين عليها وجود نمو فطري
وتعفن منتشر كما حررت مخالفه على
المستوردين لتداولهم منتجا غذائيا ملوثا
اذا نشاهد معكم مشاهدينا صور مباشره
لتساقط الامطار المصحوبه بالبرد او وردتنا
قبل قليل لتساقط البرد والامطار في الرياض
اذا هذه صور وردتنا قبل قليل لتساقط
الامطار الغزيره والمصحوبه بالبرد على
منطقه الرياض لنستمع
في السعوديه اعلنا مهرجان البحر الاحمر
السينمائي عن اختيار اثنين اثنين عشره
مشروع للمشاركه في برنامج اللودج للعام
الجاري وذلك ضمن برنامج معامل البحر
الاحمر ينطلق بالتعاون مع معمل تورينو
للافلام وبرعايه فيلم العلا لرعايه ودعم
المواهب الناشئه وتقديمها للساحه الدوليه
بموازاه ذلك اطلقت وزاره الثقافه السعوديه
فعاليه ليالي في المسعودي في فرنسا والتي
تهدف الى ترويج صناعه السينما دوليا من
خلال الافلام والنقاشات بالاضافه الى
الجلسات التفاعليه برنامج ليالي الفيلم
السعودي في فرنسا المستمر حتى الثامن عشر
من مارس يسعى ايضا الى عقد شركات جديده
ودعم صناع الافلام السعوديين من خلال
ربطهم بنظائرهم في الخارج
من مدينه تولوز الفرنسيه تنضم الينا منتجه
الافلام نور الامام اهلا بك معنا نوره اذن
انت في فرنسا الان الى ماذا يهدف برنامج
ليالي الفيلم السعودي في فرنسا ولماذا تم
اختير او اختيار فرنسا تحديدا
اهلا وسهلا يعطيكم العافيه
الهدف الرئيسي للبرنامج وليش فرنسا بالذات
زي ما ما هو معروف الثقافه الفرنسيه
بالسينما والمجتمع عموما نحس الفني جدا
عالي
وفرنسا هي تعتبر من اوائل الدول في العالم
اللي تم فيها انتاج الافلام المتحركه
عموما طيب يعني نوره انتم كصناع او
كمنتجين افلام هل يعني تشعرون بانكم
تلتقون تتلقون الدعم الكافي في مجال صناعه
الافلام
طبيعي يسال الدعم بيكون اصلا من جهات
كثيره سواء كان من القطاع الخاص او الجهات
الحكوميه في دعم باشكال مختلفه الدعم
المادي كل تمويل للافلام وفي الدعم
اللوجستي كمثلا البرامج اللي احنا حاليا
موجودين فيها في فرنسا
وفي برضو امبارح زي مثلا عندك منحه
ضوء وعموما يعني
الهيئه هيئه الافلام السعوديه وفي هذه من
اشكال التمكين او الدعم للمنتجين في
الصناعه بشكل عام
يعني انتم كمنتجين كمصانعي افلام وفي
السينما السعوديه ايش تحتاجوا ايش ينقص
السينما السعوديه لتصل الى العالميه
يعطيكم العافيه شكرا
نتابع معكم مشاهدينا مجددا صور جديده
لتساقط الامطار المصحوبه بالبرد قبل قليل
في مدينه الرياض ولنستمع الى الصوت
الطبيعي لهذه الصور
اذا كانت تلك الصور شاهدناها قبل قليل في
مدينه الرياض للامطار المصحوبه بالبرد
واما في شمال السعوديه شهدت مدينه تبوك
موجه كثيفه لتساقط الثلوج على جبال اللوز
وعلقان تحديدا لنشاهد
[موسيقى]
صور جديده ايضا لتساقط الامطار المصحوبه
بالبرد في مدينه الرياض قبل قليل نتابع
الرحمن الرياض
المطار الملك خالد الدولي
الساعه ثلاثه وواحد واربعين دقيقه من
الساعه اليوم الاربعاء
15 مارس
2000 وثلاث وعشرين ما شاء الله تبارك
الرحمن
اخوكم مبروك الشعيبي
يوم غد الخميس مشاهدينا سيتساوى طول الليل
مع النهار في جميع انحاء المعموره
التفاصيل في تقويم مع خالد ازعاج
[موسيقى]
في يوم غد الخميس سيتساوى فيه طول الليل
مع النهار على جميع انحاء المعموره وش
يعني هذا يعني ان الشمس تشرق وتغرب بنفس
موعدها وتشرق الشمس من المشرق تماما وتغرب
من المغرب تماما وتساوي الليل والنهار لا
يكون الا في يومين في السنه يوم الاعتدال
الربيعي 16 مارس ويوم الاعتدال الخريف في
27 سبتمبر رب المشرقين ورب المغربين فباي
الاء ربكما تكذبان وتساوي الليل والنهار
معناه الليل 12 ساعه والنهار 12 ساعه هذا
عندنا اما على القطب الشمالي فستشرق الشمس
ولن تغرب الا بعد سته شهور وعلى القطب
الجنوبي ستغرب الشمس ولن تشرق الا بعد سته
شهور فالليل سته اشهر والنهار سته اشهر
والليل يتقلب مع النهار طوال ايام السنه
ما عدا المناطق الواقعه على خط الاستواء
ليش لكرويه الارض ودورانها حول نفسها
ودورانها حول الشمس وميلان محور دورانها
وهذا الدوران هو العمر تمر بنا الايام
وتترى وانما نساق الى الاجال والعين تنظر
فلا عائد هذا الشباب الذي مضى ولا زائل
هذا المشيب المكدر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
نختم الرابعه بهذه الصور من الرياض والتي
تشهد تساقط امطار غزيره مصحوبه بالبرد قبل
قليل لسكان الرياض يستمتعوا بهذه الاجواء
الجميله كونوا حذرين والى اللقاء
ما شاء الله تبارك الرحمن